Schön.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Ust-Orlaren. Ich bin erst in dieser Station. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahme-Gespräch führen. Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Ich möchte.
Okay. Ich werde erst Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen. Dann komme ich gleich zu Ihrer Nachbarn-Beschwärte. Okay.
Wie heißt es Ihnen?
Mein Name ist Heinrich Böll.
Heinrich Böll. Könntest du bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachbarn-Müchtebier?
Ja, Heinrich. H-E-I-N-R-I-C-H. Heinrich. Und der Nachname ist Böll. B-B-Doppel-L.
Böll.
Okay, Herr Böll. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 52 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
22. Februar 1970.
Okay. Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Jetzt aktuell, wirklich 78, Frau Doktor.
78.
Ich habe aber ungefähr 10 kg abgenommen.
10 kg.
Aber jetzt, in den letzten Wochen habe ich wieder 3 kg zugenommen. Also ich hatte bis 75 kg.
Jetzt habe ich 78 kg.
Im letzten Zeitraum haben Sie abgenommen. Bist du nicht genau?
Ja, im letzten halben Jahr ungefähr, kann ich sagen.
60.
Okay.
Sind Sie haben Sie Ihre Gewohnheit geändert oder geändert vielleicht Bewegnungsgewohnheit?
Ja, ich habe nicht mehr so viel Appetit, aber es geht mir insgesamt nicht mehr gut.
Seit ungefähr zwei Monaten fühle ich mich nicht gut.
Ich habe auch schon davor Gewicht abgenommen.
Okay.
Also Appetit ist nicht gut, sonst werden wir weniger bewegen.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,75 m.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben 3 kg zugenommen.
Ja, in den letzten zwei Wochen wieder.
Ja, diese Gewichtsuname ist besonders an bestimmten Körperteilen oder zum Beispiel Bauch.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefangen.
Gut, dass Sie fragen, Frau Doktor.
Meine Beine sind ein bisschen dicker.
Als Bauch fühle ich mich auch dicker als vorher.
Sie haben gesagt, Beine dicker, das heißt Beinödemne oder Beinödemn.
Ja, meine Beine sind geschwollen.
Okay.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, was für Beschwerden noch haben Sie?
Frau Doktor, wie gesagt, seit einigen Monaten, ein, zwei Monate fühle ich mich einfach sehr schwach.
Ich bin abgeschlagen, müde.
Ich kann auch jetzt nicht mehr arbeiten.
Ich bin jetzt auch krank geschrieben, dass das Hauptproblem ist.
Mir ist manchmal übel, dass ich diesen Gewichtsverlust, den ich Ihnen erwähnt hatte.
Also kann auch nicht viel essen.
Wenn ich es esse, habe ich gleich so eine volle gefühle Magen auch.
Und dann kann ich auch nicht so viel essen.
Und jetzt ist es halt so einigen Tagen, ungefähr eine Woche, 10 Tage,
habe ich jetzt auch starken Yukreis bekommen, Katzen,
ich habe auch so ein paar Flecken auf der Haut.
Und dann hat mein Hausarzt, wo ich dann noch war, sagt, oh, Sie sind ja auch ein bisschen gelb in den Augen.
Und dann hat er mich jetzt ins Krankenhaus geschickt.
Okay.
Das mit den Beinen wollte ich auch sagen, das haben Sie schon gefragt,
dass meine Beine, also man unterschenkelst geschwollen.
Das ist auch so seit ungefähr einer Woche vielleicht.
Und ich hatte auch Probleme mit Nasenbluten.
Früher auch mal hatte, aber es war in letzter Zeit sehr oft gewesen.
Und jetzt in den letzten 3, 4 Tagen habe ich auch so sehr dunklen Stuhl,
der ist schwarz gewesen, war vorher aber normal.
Das sind die Sachen, die ich beobachtet habe.
Okay.
Ja, hervor Sie haben viele Beschwaben erwähnt.
Und besonders Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind gelb geworden.
Also auch mein Hausarzt hat das gesagt.
Also mir selbst ist das gar nicht aufgefallen, in den Augen, weil ich schon ein bisschen gelb.
Wurde bei Ihrem Haus weitere Untersuchungen durchgeführt?
Nein, der hat mich jetzt ins Krankenhaus geschickt,
weitere Untersuchungen abgeliehen.
Okay.
Und ja, haben Sie erbrochen?
Deswegen.
Kann ich mich nicht erinnern? Nein.
Hat übel, ist mir schon, aber erbrechen muss ich nicht dich erst einmal trauen, weniger.
Okay.
Also eigentlich ständig, aber nach dem Essen ist es dann besonders.
Aber auch, wenn ich nicht erst einmal, ist mir auch übel.
Okay.
Also eigentlich nicht unabhängig kann ich sagen.
Egal, was ich esse.
Wie ist Ihre Schlag?
Hab ich bisher eigentlich kein Problem gehabt.
Okay.
Habt ihr Schwierigkeit,
beim Atmen zu bekommen?
Atm zu.
Nee, das ist so wie immer.
Also ich habe so ein Spray vom Hausarzt, das nehme ich manchmal, wenn ich Luftnot habe,
ist das nicht irgendwie schlechter als vorher.
Sie haben Luftnot, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Also Luftnot habe ich nicht.
Ich habe das nicht.
Also der Hausarzt hat mir so ein Spray gegeben, das kommt vom Rauchen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Wenig auf und bewege mich wenig, deswegen kann ich jetzt sitzen liegen, kein Problem.
Okay.
Ich habe das nicht.
Also da habe ich die Hochzeit
Ich mache auch nicht viel.
Haben Sie auch zitternde Hände bemerkt?
Kann ich so es nicht sagen?
Okay.
Oder außer diese gelbe Farbe, eine Hautveränderung haben Sie bemerkt?
Die Lach, ein Blut?
Also ich hatte verschiedene Punkte gehabt, auch am Bauch.
Aber dann hatte ich juckreis, ich habe es nicht schon gesagt.
Ja, Siehaben schon gesagt.
Habt ihr Alergie?
Mir ist bisher nie etwas bekannt gewesen.
Oder unverträgliche Geschwärts, normalerweise.
Habt ihr Probleme bei im Wasserlast?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Siehaben sparsen Sturl in den letzten drei Tagen.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Einmal täglich.
Okay.
Süriahaben Sie Probleme beim Sturl, haben Sie z.B. Verstopfung?
Nein, habe ich keine Probleme gehabt bisher.
Herr Böhl, rachen Sie?
Ja, ich rache ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten rachen Sie denn?
Es werden so 15 bis 20 Zigaretten sein pro Tag.
Seit wann?
Seitdem ich 18 bin.
16, vielleicht war ich auch 16, ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Was trinken Sie?
Ich trinke meistens Bier, auch auf der Arbeit trinken wir Bier.
Ich trinke meistens 6 Back pro Tag.
6 Back?
Ja.
Wie viel trinken Sie wieder?
6 Back, 6 Flaschen.
Manchmal mehr, manchmal weniger.
Trinken Sie noch weitere?
Selten, meistens ist es nur Bier.
Okay.
Haben Sie Alfaar mit dem Drogen?
Nein, ich bin keine Drogen.
Okay.
Sie sind Racherwüsten.
Was meinen Sie?
Sie haben chronische Wüsten.
Sie haben wegen der Zigaretten.
Morgen knüpfen.
Deswegen brauchen Sie Spray.
Nein, das Spray hat er mir gegeben, weil ich ab und zu sagte,
ein bisschen Luft knapp manchmal rälten.
Dann hat er gesagt, nehmen Sie halt das Spray.
Aber es ist keine Hüste.
Nicht so viel, nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich habe schon gesagt, dass wir nicht mehr schlafen.
Aber es ist eine Flachlinie.
Ja.
Nein, sonst wie früher auch.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie an irgendwelchen Folgerfragen?
Nein, ich mag nicht.
Ich kann nicht.
Zum Beispiel Blutzuckerkrankheit,
Scyttoxinprobleme.
Ich nehme nur Blutdrucken-Tabletten.
Ja, die habe ich schon seit 5, 6 Jahren.
Da hat der Hausarzt mir aufgeschrieben.
Was nehmen Sie rein?
Das sind zwei Tabletten.
Das eine heißt Ramelich.
Das andere heißt Amlotipin.
Wie sind Sie die Dosierung?
Ja, das sind beides 5 Milligramm.
Nur ein, oder?
Ja, nehme ich beides.
Und, wo dünn Sie bis hier operiert?
Ja, ich hatte mal einen Arbeitsunfall.
Da habe ich mir den Unterschenkel gebrochen.
Das ist operiert worden.
Das ist auch schon 10 Jahre her.
Und dann hatte ich noch früher,
da war ich aber noch jung,
eine Blinddarm-Operation gehabt.
Ja, und das waren die Operationen,
wo ich im Krankenhaus war.
Sind diese Operationen problemlos verlassen?
Ja, da gab es keine Problemen.
Okay.
Wie ist die Lebenszeit?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, mein Vater ist gestorben.
Woher ist ihr Vater gestorben?
Er hat Lungenkrebs.
Okay.
Und wie ist die Lebenszeit?
Sie haben sich an irgendeinem
Leben gebrochen.
Die hat ein paar Krankheiten.
Die hat Blutzucker.
Sie spritzt die Insulin.
Sie ist schon 80 Jahre alt.
Und hat auch Herzprobleme.
Sie hat Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Herzprobleme hat sie und Zucker.
Hast du eine Schwester?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder und eine Schwester.
Die jüngere Schwester.
Der Bruder hat auch Probleme mit Bluthochdruck und Herz.
Die Schwester ist eigentlich gesund.
Bluthochdruck und Herzprobleme.
Ja, Herzprobleme.
Missionsdiversität-Probleme?
Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Sein learn?
Ja.
Okay.
Und wie ist dein Leben?
Ich lebe allein.
Wie ist dein Mandarin?
Ich lebe alleine.
Wie ist dein Schikot?
Ich habe eine Frage. Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Ja, das übliche halt.
Was machen Sie für die Frage?
Ich arbeite auf dem Bau. Ich bin Maurer.
Maurer.
Okay, seit wann sind Sie krankgeschrieben?
Also jetzt bin ich schon drei Wochen krankgeschrieben.
Davor habe ich auch schon mal, also vor zwei Monaten auch schon mal, zwei Wochen krankgeschrieben.
Wegen dieser Beschwaben?
Ja, ja.
Okay, ich weiß.
Harald, sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Ja, ich habe drei Empfängen.
Und waren Sie im Ausland seit den sechsten Monaten?
Nein, ich fahre nicht in Ausland. Ich mache Urlaub hier an der Ostsee meistens.
Okay, ich fahre nicht.
Haben Sie diese Probleme, so erst mal erlebt oder sind diese Beschwaben schon aufgetreten?
Nein, die sind jetzt so, in den letzten Monaten neu, hatte ich früher nicht.
Okay, früher.
Ja.
Ja, Herr Wohl, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen in der Gestalt und ja Sie haben eigentlich viele Beschwerden.
Wir mussten jetzt sie unterzuchen.
Erst werde ich sie körperlich unterzuchen, dann wollte ich abnehmen und auch einige Unterzuchungsmethode
düşen, wie Abdominal-Röscher.
Muss ich da bleiben, muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben oder?
Ja, ja.
Ich kann nicht rausgehen.
Okay, also Sie können nicht sagen, wie Tag ich im Krankenhaus bleiben muss?
Nein, ich kann nicht sagen, dass ich von Ihnen hergebt bin.
Okay, okay.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Blutabende und Ultraschall?
Ja, ich werde jetzt sie körperlich unterzuchen, dann muss ich Blut abnehmen.
Ich muss einige Blutwerte unterzuchen, dann werde ich sie wieder überwärtsen.
Ich werde sie überwärtsen, dann werde ich sie wieder überwärtsen.
Sie haben Gelbsucht, das heißt Sie leiden vielleicht an einem Nebergrankheit.
Also ich bin nicht gelb, aber...
Ja, Sie haben Gelbeagung, deswegen wenig Interess.
Ja, vielleicht, dass kann später auf Zikön in Iran halt werden.
Okay, und ist das Gelbsucht, ist das ansteckend oder ist das gefährlich?
Ja, ich kann nicht genanzt sagen, ich muss einige Blutunterzuchen, dann düşen.
Vielleicht, dass kann ein Hepetite sein, aber ja, eigentlich...
Das ist ansteckend, ja?
Ja, natürlich, ansteckend.
Okay, ja, Harbun, jetzt bitte nehmen Sie Platz, ich komme gleich.
Alles klar, einfach dann, Frau Doktor, ich warte auf Sie.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Zeit 1, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, fertig denken kann.
Schon immer, seitdem ich arbeite, seit ich arbeite schon seit 30 Jahren auf dem Bau.
Bauarbeiter trinken oft leider Alkohol, soll kein Vorurteil sein, aber ist oft so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es gefragt wurde, vielleicht habe ich es nicht gehört.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Hat sie nicht gefragt, glaube ich, aber ich habe keine Fieber, nein.
Haben Sie Katzschweißigkeit?
Auch nicht.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden?
Keine Schluckbeschwerden, ja.
Wie sieht aus, Schwarz?
Schwarz war schwarz gewesen, dunkel.
Aber die haben eine Flüchtlingsblutung gesehen.
Ich habe kein Blut gesehen, nein.
Irgendwelche Bauchschmerzen haben.
Hat so eine volle Gefühl im Oberbau.
Und diese Bescheidung war schwarz.
Dunkel, schwarz.
Nein, von der Konsistenz normal.
Ich habe nur differenzial die Diagnose gefragt.
Sie haben einmal eine Transition erhalten.
Eine gute Frage, weiß er nicht.
Sind Sie Kinderkrankheit, Vollständige gift?
Weiß er nicht.
Aber jetzt ein paar Fragen, ich gehe mal ganz kurz in den Chat.
Urin, hat sich Farbesurin verändert, gute Frage.
Urin ist ein bisschen dunkler als sonst, ja.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Das haben wir besprochen, das ist eher so volle Gefühl, Druckgefühl, Oberbau.
Keine Schmerzen in dem Sinne, aber es ist unwohl sein,
beziehungsweise beschwerden hat er im Oberbau.
Haben Sie Geschlechtverkehr mit jemandem,
die Sie nicht früher kennengelernt haben?
Auch sehr gute Frage, hat er nicht gehabt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass das Nasenboleten Epistaxi ist.
Haben Sie mal irgendwann Ihre Nase gebrochen?
Stimmt, da ist Nase gebrochen früher mal.
Er kann sich nicht erinnern, er weiß nicht genau.
Können Sie die Nasenboleten genau beschreiben, die oft am Taxi,
zum Beispiel, und wie viel Ministern da wird?
Ist nicht jeden Tag, aber häufiger als früher.
Als früher schon mal Nasenboleten gab es es häufiger, aber nicht jeden Tag.
Das ist auch so jetzt seit einer Woche ungefähr.
Diese Beschwerden sind Sie schon mal im Haushalts gewesen?
Also er weiß beim Haushalts mit den Sperren, die er jetzt hier genannt hat, sonst nicht.
Vorher nicht.
Jetzt aktuell nicht, der hat einen Kacken ausgeschickt den Patienten.
Meine Fragen, das war es.
Andere Fragen haben Kollegen?
Ich gibt keine anderen Fragen, Sie haben schon alles gefragt.
Bauchdrücke für die Müdigkeit?
Ja, Bauchdrücke für die Müdigkeit, das sind beides vorhanden, das sind beichern.
Druckgefühl, Völdergefühl, Oberbau und Müdigkeit, Abgestragenheit, Leistungsbinderung.
Fettstuhl, Fragen, oder nicht?
Ja, aber die müssen den Patienten erklären, was Fettstuhl ist, was ist Fettstuhl,
woher soll er das wissen, weil er es nicht hatte.
Irre stütte.
Wie fragen Sie?
Lehmung und Schleichung.
Lehmung ist anders. Lehmartig vielleicht?
Lehmartig, glänzende.
Glänzende, ja, das sind so Fragen, die man machen kann.
Nee, das war nicht der Fall. Also, in den letzten Tagen hatte er diesen dunklen schwarzen Stuhl gehabt.
Mundgeruch, weiß er nicht.
Das spricht man selbst dann nicht mehr, und hat jetzt keine Frau, die ihm sagen kann, wo Mundgeruch hat.
Kann man nichts sagen, bewusstlos war er nicht.
Herzrasen gefragt, oder? Herzrasen, Herr Stolpern.
Haben wir nicht gefragt, aber jetzt keine Beschwerden in der Hinsicht.
Sehr gut.
Als Geschwindigkeit anfangen, können wir anfangen?
Wenn keine Fragen sind, gehen wir zum Oberarztgespräch, ja?
Ja.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient nachgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen vorstellen, hätten Sie dafür sein?
Jawoll, ich habe fünf Minuten Zeit, Sie müssen sich beeilen.
Ich muss zum nächsten Mal beeilen.
Okay, danke.
Es handelt sich um Henry Spür.
Er ist 276 Jahre alt, 70 kg schwer und ein Meta 75 groß.
Er kann heute wegen einer oder zwei Monaten, 5 T-Hände, volle Gefüll im Oberbau und auch Abgeschlagungheit,
so viel Müdigkeit zu unskern.
Er hat auch in den letzten sechs Monaten ungefähr 10 kg Abgenommung untern in den letzten Wochen
3 kg wieder zugenommt.
Er berichtete, dass sein Bauchunfall dicker geworden sei.
und die Begleitungs- und Bechwertung von Folgen, die Symptome,
die Nausea, die Apathens- und Priorität, die Stichleren,
die Icterus, die Nazimbulutung, die Epistaxis,
die Beinödemähen, die Konzentration der Störungen
und seit der Bechwertung von Folgen, die Melena,
er leidet an Arterielleki Partone seit 5.00 Uhr sechs.
Trinkt.
Ja, und er racht ungefähr 5.00 oder 20.00 Uhr
täglich seit seinem sechsten Lebensjahr.
Sechsten Lebensjahr? Hat er als Kind angefangen?
Ja.
Mit sechs Jahren?
Hat so gesagt.
Hat echte meinte, ja?
Sechsten.
Ja, ich schuldigung.
Er hat keine Allergie und in der Familienanenmese findet sich
Bronchial Crips, Todesurzache,
Bayenfata und Zainmuta leidet an Diabetesmilitus
und bekommt, sie bekommt Insünin, Injektion
und auch sie hat an myocardinfarktis gelikt.
Zainburuda leidet an Arterielleki Partone
und hat auch Herzprobleme.
Der Patient ist vor 10 Jahren
unter Schenkel-Wegnen-Anfraktur operiert worden.
Auch als Jugend hat er apandektumiert,
und er Impfstatus ist vollständig,
aber Kinderkrankheit, Impfstatus ist unbekannt.
Er ist mauer, als Beruf, es ist ein Schiedener,
mauer, mauer, mauer, mauer, mauer.
Und es ist ein Schiedener, lebt elend,
und er hat Kanken,
und er hat auch eine
Kehme, kehme unkusfantropile, unkusstodini, magunkarsinum, magunkarsinum inbetracht.
Okay, also gehen Sie von der Leberzirose aus bei den Patienten am ersten, ja?
Ja, am ersten denke daran, wegen der Osefraguerl barissen, ja.
Ja, die Osefraguerl barizen, wissen Sie das schon?
Ich weiß schon nicht, aber er hat Tierstuhl, deswegen habe ich das gedacht und er fühlt sich schwach.
Okay.
Auch ja, und er trinkt viel Alkohol täglich, ungefähr sechs Flachen Bier.
Okay, okay, okay.
Aber gibt es noch andere Gründe für den Tierstuhl? Also muss es unbedingt Osefraguerl barizen sein?
Nein, eine Blutung in der Oberagasson Testen, also kann diese Beschwerde verursachen.
Unkusfantropile, unkusstodini, magunkrips kann verursachen, ja.
Okay, und wenn es kein Ulkos ist?
Magunkrips.
Wenn kein Ulkos und kein Magunkrips ist, kann man trotzdem bluten?
Ja, Osefragus Karcinom, Pilarsch, auch.
Also, okay, kein Karcinom, kein Ulkos.
Gibt es noch andere Ursachen für Blutung?
Keine Krankheit, wo man bluten kann.
Ja, aber wie erwartet Kolom Karcinom auch Pilarsch?
Oh, es wird kompliziert.
Ja, es wird kompliziert.
Ja, diese Beschwerde kann sich um die Leberzirose haben.
Ja, also davon gehe ich, also wie es Schülern denke ich auch, dass eine Leberzirose hat, und dann gibt es...
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Er hat Konzentrationsschritteurungen. Er kann auch an einem, ja, dass das Amunjak ist höchst sein.
Deswegen kann das eine Encephalopathy verursachen.
Okay, so eine Komplikation der Leberzirose, ja. Kennen Sie die klinische Klassifikation der Leberzirose?
Es gibt eine Charles-Klassikation.
Ich habe auch ein Album von Ulubin. Es gibt auch eine Encephalopathy.
Welche 3 Klasse?
Was ist das Schlimmste an Bambai Child?
3 ist Schlimmste, aber Acid-Asephalopathy.
Wenn man mal einen Rupter haben, heißt ABC.
ABC ist eine gottgeschütte Leberzirose.
Wenn eine Hepatite-Asephalopathy und Acid es gibt, auch Blutwerte ist nicht gut, ist das heißt Child 3, oder?
Man macht dann einen Punktescore von diesen Faktoren.
Nachdem wir die Punkte sind, kann es ABC oder C sein.
Wie ist die Prognose bei Child C, wenn es eine ganz schlimme Leberzirose ist?
Die Prognose ist nicht so gut. Deswegen können wir eine Lebertransplantation sehen.
Jetzt kommen wir mal langsam.
Wie viele Patienten mit Child C leben denn ein Jahr?
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, aber vielleicht ist es schon gut.
Ich habe noch 30% Leben.
An Drittel überlebt ein Jahr.
Die anderen sterben.
Das ist eine ernste Prognose.
Sie haben ein Labor abgenommen.
Die ganzen Parameter sind wichtig.
Auch Gerinnungswerte.
Von Blutbild her gibt es auch manchmal Probleme.
Es hat eine Patientischlechte, die Gerinnungswerte.
Wir haben früher gesagt, Quik ist niedrig.
Es gibt auch andere.
Trombocytopen.
Trombocytopen kann noch spontan bluten.
Manchmal kann es auch mit der oberen gastrinistischen Blutung sein.
Manchmal kann es sein, dass er plötzlich blutet.
Ohne Ulkust, ohne Tumor.
Ja, Ulkust, Tumor, Perforation.
Manchmal ist es auch so, dass eine Gastriptis Blutung machen kann.
Manchmal kann es auch homorhagisch sein.
Und dass der Patent Ulkust oder Tumor hat.
Weil die Gerinnungswerte schlecht sind.
Das würden Sie mit der Endoskopie untersuchen.
Ich werde eine endoskopische Untersuchung beschwörend.
Jetzt haben Sie einige Komplikationen genannt von der Leberzirose.
Einmal haben Sie gesagt, dass Enzephylopatie auftreten kann.
Ja, Portalhypertension, Acides, Spontane, Peritonitis,
Bakterieleperitonitis, Cannesine,
Obergassointestinart, Blutung,
Wegen der Portalhypertension Cannesine, Hepatogonase,
Hepatopulmarasandrum.
Das sind so Komplikationen.
Was ist bei den Patienten am 1.
die Ursache für eine Leberzirose?
Alkohol, häufig ist Ursache Alkoholkonsum.
Dann Hepatitis B und C.
Es gibt noch weitere Krankheiten wie Hemorostosis,
Rilsons, Primer Sclerosanocodangitis.
Auch Medikamente,
Meditatorxatrisen, Leberzirose,
Das sind selten andere,
das ist bei uns Alkoholikopatriotoxisch-Leberzirose.
Wie können Sie den Patienten behandeln?
Was kann man therapeutisch machen bei den Leberzirosen?
Ja, therapeutisch werde ich bei der Undoskopie unterdrücken
diese Blutung stelle.
Mit einem Clips zum Beispiel,
oder mit einem Clips oder Sphitlerisierung,
kann ich versuchen.
Wenn es eine erosiv-hemoralische Gastritis ist,
können Sie dann auch Clips machen?
Nein.
Vielleicht kann eine Sphitlerotherapie oder eine Injektion
ausrechnen.
Wenn man das lokalisieren kann,
ist es meistens so, dass es die Fuse ist.
Dann kann man das lokalisieren.
Entweder macht man die Therapie der Gastritis
mit Protonpumpinibitoren.
Seltenfällen kann man auch so koagulieren
mit Argonbiemersummal.
Es ist sehr selten notwendig.
Es ist meistens so, dass die Patienten
keine aktive Blutung haben,
sondern nur Zeichen der stattgeabten Blutung.
Da muss man nichts machen.
Das kommt davon vor.
Was sagen Sie den Patienten?
Was soll er machen?
Dann sprennerlektronisch einhalten.
Das ist wichtig.
Es muss auch eine Asylkumpion sein
bei den Patienten.
Ich werde es aktuell geben,
wenn ich eine Entsuffelopatis habe.
Sie hat jetzt nicht so viel.
Sie hat es vorliegt.
Was noch?
Warum hatte er den Acidis und Ödem?
Acidis und Ödem wegen der Portalipartition.
Aber auch die Ödem in Beinen als Portalipartition?
Auch Lieberfunktion ist nicht gut. Albuminwerte ist gering.
Beine, Ödem, Einstein.
Was kann man dagegen tun?
Den Albuminmangel.
Dann war es Albumintherapie.
Kann man substitutieren.
Es ist nicht so gern gesehen, weil es nicht so einen guten und langen Effekt hat.
Aber das ist meistens ein Zusammenspiel zwischen Leberfunktion, Lebersyntese-Störung.
Und aber auch dann indirekt auch Mangelernährung.
Sie ernähren sich ja auch nicht, weil sie nur Alkohol trinken und Igulkeit ausmitten.
Was können Sie da machen?
Natürlich werde ich Lebersyntese-Störung empfehlen.
Alkoholkaren ist sehr wichtig.
Alkoholkaren ist ein proteinreiches Ernährungsstil.
Ich werde auch empfehlen.
Flüssigkeit, geringe Flüssigkeit auch empfehlen.
Da hat ihr mal auch schon geschrieben, glaube ich,
dass man dann auch entsprechend Vitaminen substitutiert, auch wenn er gerührt wird.
Ja, klar.
Der und Karten, ja.
Und dann haben Sie auch schon genannt, wenn es ein Spätstadium ist,
also man nicht mehr so viel machen kann mit Medikamenten oder sonstigen Maßnahmen.
Haben Sie eine Therapie schon erwähnt?
Ja, Leber-Transplantation ist dann.
Was ist Ihre Ersetzung dafür?
Wir müssen sicher sein, dass der Patient ungefähr sechs Monate keinen Alkohol getrunken hat.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Ja, also er muss trocken sein unbedingt.
Eine Folge noch, eine Komplikation, länger durch den Leber-Zeroz.
Da muss man auch immer denken.
Was kann noch passieren, wenn eine Patient eine langsame chronische Leber-Zeroze hat?
Ja, Leber-Karsen.
Konnixten ja.
Hat Hepatocillaris-Karzinom, ja.
Gut, dann haben Sie einiges, glaube ich, hier sehr gut zusammengetragen.
Darf ich mal kurz mal in den Chat gucken, was noch da geschrieben worden ist?
Ich konnte nicht alles drücken.
Wo fängt es an?
Also die Prognose, Gerinnuchtörungen,
die sind ein Jahr zu über dem Staat, der ja 30% ungefähr.
Portal über Vitamin K, Karzinom, PWS.
So eine Matastotintherapie bei varizen Blutung kann man überlegen,
aber primär ist das natürlich eine endoskopische Therapie, ja,
bei den akut Varizenbluten.
Was kann man machen, wenn Varizenbluten endoskopisch?
Laserargontherapie.
Am Anfang können wir Beta-Blocken vielleicht empfehlen, wenn keine Blutung gibt.
Warum machen Sie Beta-Blocke?
Diese Portal-Tension, wie kann man sagen?
Denken, den portalen Druck zu senken, ja.
Ja, zu senken, ja.
Und da macht man in der Regel gerne so eine Varizenligatur, ja,
also meistens umigemalteligatur.
Es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeiten der Sklerosierung von Varizen.
Ich habe es gesagt, aber ja, Sklerosierung.
Gut, aber wie gesagt, es kann auch sein, dass der Patient,
wie ich nur eine Gastritis hatte,
bei dieser schlechten Gerinnung und der Trombocytopäne,
einfach daraus blutet, da können Sie sich jetzt nicht viel machen.
Ja, dann...
Auf der Epidemie und Blutgerinnungssituation verbessern, ja.
Wir müssen vorliegende Ursache behandeln.
Genau, also Grinsfaktoren stabilisieren.
Präsent, ja, präsent, frisch, löscht.
Ich gehe jetzt unter Albuminmang, haben wir gesprochen,
über proteinreiche Ernährung, Vitamin, Substitution,
Katzenum, Hepatopulmonalsyndrom, Hepatarinalsyndrom,
Sklerotellapy, sehr, ich glaube, die wichtigsten Sachen
haben wir, glaube ich, schon besprochen gehabt, gell?
Sehr gut, also haben Sie sehr umfangreich und kompetent behandelt, ja.
Rima, gibt es sonst noch Ergänzung?
Hat Sie gut, sehr gut gemacht, die Frau Doktor.
Sogar der Oberarzt ist sprachlos und sehr zufrieden,
obwohl es ein böse Oberarzt war.
Ich habe viele Frage, Schwergesunabart.
Das war das Wichtigste, war da, absolut, ja.
Wie können wir uns eine Mese gespritzt empfangen, am besten?
Da gibt es, glaube ich, keine einheitliche Regel.
Es waren Kollegen verschieden, wie es jetzt gemacht worden ist,
mit den allgemeinen Angaben, Namen,
wie Teilparametergewichts und so weiter,
das sind so die allgemeinen Fragen, dann kann man normalerweise
dann die akuten Beschwerden erfragen, wie Sie es gemacht haben.
Das ist jetzt schon sehr gut gewesen, ja.
Also, so ein bestimmter Schema, wie Sie es eben die Kollegen machen.
Können wir nennen diese Erschöpfung, Müdigkeit Fatik oder andere Börter?
Kann man sagen, ja, Fatik, ja.
Also, Erschöpfungstzustand, ja.
Worauf man achten sollte, vielleicht bei der Oberarztvorstellung,
wäre das jetzt nicht in die Details zu sehr,
also, wenn es jetzt ein Patient ist mit Leberzirose, ja,
war das ja ziemlich klar mit Alkohol und Absäum.
Dann müssen Sie zum Beispiel jetzt die anderen Sachen
mit der Familienanamese jetzt nicht so ausführlich machen,
dass der Bruder Bluthochdruck hat oder so was,
das würde ich weglassen, glaube ich.
Ja, okay.
Wir sagen Familienanamese ist diesbezüglich nicht,
richtungsweise ein Punkt, ja.
Der Oberarzt hat keine Zeit für sowas, ja.
Das bringt in diesem Fall nicht viel bei zur Krankheitssituation
oder auch so Details Sachen, die jetzt nicht wichtig sind.
Das weiß man manchmal nicht, aber manchmal hat man das Gefühl,
das ist nicht so wichtig, weil Impfung oder so was
bei den Patienten ist nicht so wichtig.
Oder in seinem Fall diese Vorerkennung,
die Operation, haben Sie auch ganz kurz gemacht, ist wichtig.
Sagen wir Voroperation, Fraktur, Abendermie-Punkt,
nicht zu sagen, das war da und da gewesen.
Also, wenn es die aktuelle Problematik nicht wichtig ist,
dann sollte man das kurz fassen.
Weil der Oberarzt hat keine Zeit, er muss sich fokussieren.
Er braucht die wichtigsten Informationen ab einmal.
Aber das war schon sehr gut.
Haben Sie sich schon ziemlich gut fokussiert auch, ja.
Ja, wie immer.
Sehr gut.
Wann ist Ihre Prüfung?